des pièces plus lumineuse divers
services proposés à l'escale aujourd'hui
trois services de la petite enfance
travaillent en collaboration
chaque espace est interconnecté comme on
dit ce qui fait qu si on a le personnel
municipal qui peut travailler dans le
parcours de l'enfant
et puis c'est aussi en centre ville donc
beaucoup plus accessible nous avons
regroupé l'ensemble de ces structures
la microcrèche leur l'assistante
maternelle qui était dans le quartier
des friches et l'espace enfants par an
dans des lieux beaucoup plus grand plus
de 300 m² dédiés aux enfants de moins de
trois ans avec 20 berceaux pour la ltte
jeu et 10 en fondant la microcrèche une
nouvelle structure ouverte deux mois
plus tôt est déjà victime de son succès
sur la micro crèche on reste à 10
enfants puisque de toute façon c'est là
c'est la norme
on ne peut pas augmenter des dix enfants
mais sur l'espace enfants parents et
même au niveau du relais assistants
maternels la fréquentation est beaucoup
plus importante depuis qu'on est au
centre-ville avant l espace enfants
parents n'accueillait 5 6 enfants par
accueille là on arrive à 14,15 par
l'accueil situé dans l'ancien espace
solidarité l'escale a nécessité un
budget de 2 128 mille euros plus de
soixante mille euros ont été
subventionnés par la caisse
d'allocations familiales